[Music]
now up top i just want to apologize for
the
absolute disasters that were my video
uploads last week
i ended up posting the episode 5
breakdown four times
because the first two had audio sync
issues with them then the third got
blocked by adult swim
and then as i posted the fourth version
the blocking on that got lifted
i'm guessing that the company were just
flagging any video using footage due to
episode 7 being leaked
and i just want to say it was super
frustrating for me and i can imagine
very frustrating for you so sorry now
episode 6 has a lot of easter eggs in it
things you missed and hidden details
that we're going to be breaking down in
this video
the entry is called rick and morty
thanks exploitation spectacular
and the opening is clearly based on the
film national treasure starring nicholas
cage
that movie followed a treasure hunter
who discovered a map on the back of the
declaration of independence
this episode takes place on thanksgiving
which is of course a celebration of the
founding of america
and early on it contains several
landmarks and nuts towards this
the opening scene starts off with its
focus on the american flag
and we pull back to reveal several eagle
heads and there's also bursts of what i
believe are george washington
abraham lincoln and andrew jackson
probably gonna be completely wrong in
there but i actually went to josh from
the denim nerds and he said he thinks
it's jackson
and that the pistols we see could be
calling back to his long history of
dueling
so go to him and complain if it's wrong
but if not then shout him for making me
not sound as stupid as i normally do
now the pieces quickly cut short when
rick launches a remote control car out
of a portal
which covers the cameras and crashes
into the bust throughout our breakdowns
we have talked about how the portal gun
wasn't present early on in the season at
all
and this might have confirmed that the
rig we were following was actually a
decoy
it seems like the last two episodes may
have contained the real one
as it's appeared yet again and decoys of
course weren't allowed to travel into
space or to other dimensions now the
pair are there to steal the constitution
and morty asks if they're gonna put it
back to which rick says it's pretty
useless
outside of the instructions to run a
country and its secret treasure map
this is of course a callback to national
treasure and the plot of that film which
we talked about before
the pair go to break into the safe and
above it we can see the official motto
of the us in god we trust
again i promise i try to do as much
research as possible
i feel very bad if all this is wrong but
yeah the video isn't coming down no
matter what now from here we can see
some cool little details on the
constitution itself
with the words we the people being how
it starts this is a phrase that is right
at the top of the document
and its usage has appeared in several
media properties such as the song we the
people by a tribe called quest
and the netflix show of the same name
which both have themes of equality at
their core
rick and morty clearly have no respect
for american history and outside the
safe we can see the remote control car
making it look like the soldiers have
wet themselves morty then fires a gun
off which destroys the constitution
the head of the lincoln memorial and
also the liberty bell
the bell especially is placed to look
exactly like how it does in real life
and lincoln is also shot in the back of
the head which is how the real life
figure was assassinated
but very very dark humor and researching
this
i think morty might have also shot the
part of the constitution
which abolished slavery which
lasts lastly the weapon hits the statue
of liberty
to reveal that it's actually a giant
robot sent in as a trojan horse by the
french
the statue was actually gifted by the
french and i love how the torch turns
into a sword and the tablet is shield
in case you don't know the term trojan
horse comes from when the greeks used a
giant horse that they presented a troy
during a war between the two locations
this was actually a ruse and through it
they snuck soldiers in
and used it to win the war so it's clear
that france were up to something
azerik says you can never trust the
french but you know who you can trust
the heavy spoilers show hosted by me
now before we get into the breakdown i
also just want to say thank you for
checking this out and if you're enjoying
the video so far then please smash the
thumbs up button
and don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns on rick and morty every week
now after destroying the constitution
the president is pretty annoyed
and we get a return of keith david a lot
earlier than i was expecting
the pair pretty much hate each other and
he's labeled riker terrorist
which as rick says is a pretty overused
term right now
the troops are sent in and they cover
the house in an anti-portal shimmer
which is a reference to annihilation in
that film
a purple and blue sort of force field
surrounded an area
and though it doesn't change those
inside like that movie it's clearly
pulling from that film
jerry says that he can't wait to see
what it does to his prostate
and the character later undercooks the
turkey because it fries the oven clock
soldiers try and rush the house and this
springs a giant killer plant
which is riffing on audrey ii from
little shop of horrors
rick decides that he's gonna have to get
a presidential turkey pardon
which is actually a real thing according
to google this was started in 1963 when
jfk
said let's keep him going to a turkey
which began
a loose tradition that i'll talk about
later on now rick apparently has done
this a lot
and the president's onto him normally
ricky used to turkey wrangler but we
learned that this one has been killed
and that the turkeys are being
transported by truck the constant cuts
between the two as they try and trump
one another is hilarious
and it basically sets up the majority of
the episode the president's vice dwayne
is pretty worried about new york being
invaded by the french
but the president's fixation on rick has
driven him to make that the most
important thing i was kind of hoping
that this entire plot would be revealed
to be all part of rick's plan
and that he actually wanted things to go
haywire so he could become allies with
the president once more
but they don't end up revealing that
sadly however that is my head cannon
right now
and we watch his marines are brought in
to help the main one of these i think is
based on jeremy renner's character from
the hurt locker
william james william was addicted to
war and
rather than staying at home with his
wife and family he kept returning to
active duty
this is something that we see coop doing
and the name coop could be a nod to
bradley cooper who played chris kyle an
american sniper
he refers to rick as a spikey head
doctor who and i suppose
rig is in a way and we watches all the
soldiers have pickup trucks and a
pregnant wife
they're transformed into turkeys in
order to infiltrate henderson's turkey
farm
and this idea of changing a soldier or
law enforcement agent has been laced
throughout things such as captain
america
and also face off henderson's form is
where turkeys who might get pardoned by
the president live
i love how that little sign is followed
up by tommy's turkey transport
which is proudly transporting turkeys
who might get pardoned by the president
rick uses robot decoys as a distraction
which calls back to episode 2
and he sneaks on board the truck the
army uses what they call a david blaine
box
which is a reference to when the
magicians spent 44 days in a glass box
suspended next to tower bridge in london
realizing that no david blaine box would
be able to hold rick
the president figures out it's a trick
and he goes in himself
we see them moved into the turkey
selection pen which says that it's been
there since 1947
but after doing extensive kevin spoilers
research
yeah jfk was apparently the first
president to do it
i couldn't find another record of one
until 1989 when ronald reagan did it
and george w bush was on record as
saying that he got the idea from him
since bush it's been somewhat of a
tradition with every other president
carrying it out
and no doubt joe biden will be the next
to make sure that this great staple of
american culture
doesn't get forgotten don't know what
i'm laughing about yeah
my my country is an absolute joke right
now but moving on now rick actually
panics at one point
and the president realizes that he and
morty have snuck in
he calls coob a stump humper which i
found out today means someone that has
sex with a cow
he says not to tell 10 of his friends
that he called him that
and we learned that dwayne was only kept
around to appeal to the rural white
population of america
everything goes haywire and martinez
ends up losing it because he can't
handle seeing
270 degrees this is actually a fact
and turkeys have a much wider peripheral
vision than humans do
the tracking device inside the president
ends up landing inside another turkey
and thus we get the rise of the turkey
president
this is a man who keeps giving the
senate pay rises so that they constantly
vote in favor of his decisions
and hey we're getting pretty political i
kind of feel like when he's changed he's
crouched down to look like the
terminator
but this is also clearly done because
it's the stance that he would normally
take as a turkey
all the turkeys are dropped into the
feeding chamber which we learn is where
fdr has been turned into a giant spider
now i want to give a huge shout outs to
zee for mp on reddit for pointing out
that this amazing easter egg
calls back to gravity falls fdr was
famous for saying there's nothing to
fear but fear itself
and in gravity falls quentin tremly
becomes the eighth and a half president
and he says there's nothing to fear but
a giant man eating spider
this is pretty much what fdr becomes and
in the episode the saying changes up to
there's nothing to fear but me
we learn that he was transformed into a
half spider due to the polio vaccine
experiments
and in real life franklin suffered from
this disease
it left him wheelchair bound however the
president managed to hide his paralysis
throughout the years through several
clever means
and he would use people in railings to
prop himself up
the president talks about facebook and
how it's pretty much ruined democracy
which yeah let's be honest it has morty
manages to kill fdr
which is the further desecration of an
american icon
and yet this episode has no chill
elsewhere president turkey has more and
more turkeys turned into humans
but things are turned up to 1 000 so
that they can be more than that
he sells new york to france and gives
all of the money to congress
and this is clearly a comment on how
easily they can be bought
they clearly prefer his way to the real
presidents and thus he has to team up
with rick and morty to take him down
the family all have thanksgiving
together and there's some great lines in
this like rick saying countries are
pretty much job placement programs for
the people who run them
the president calls him fight club
because of this and they watch a charlie
kaufman reboot of wizard of oz
in which the scarecrow is writing a
screenplay without a brain
kaufman is behind films such as being
john malkovich and i'm thinking of
ending things
and all his films have a unique
weirdness to them which i actually like
so little fact about me there
now during this a report comes on in
which we see that the turkey president
is creating more and more humanoids
and that he's also launching the
washington monument into space
the key lies in the crypt of the new
world and the president recruits the
soldiers from the war who are devastated
that america is changing
coop says what would johnny cash and
dale earnhardt say
and the former was an american country
singer whilst the ladder was a nascar
driver
who sadly died in his final lap of the
daytona 500 in 2001.
the bartender says he doesn't serve the
president's kind there
and we learn that this is because of an
unpaid bar tab left behind by jimmy
carter
he decides not to serve him anyway
because well he's racist and the
president delivers an inspirational
speech
this is just a list of repeated words
and the marines
lock and load at the monument a decoy
rick and morty arrive in an unlicensed
star wars at hat or as the millennials
say
8080. now shout outs to massive shout
outs to this reference because
every time i call an attack in a star
wars breakdown
i get so many comments about how i've
said it wrong and how i'm an idiot
but we were here first yeah we were here
first
attack kids unite now this leads to all
that war and as the monument launches
they head towards the crypt of the new
world which is located below the
beheaded lincoln memorial
in here we see that america was
originally ruled by giant turkey
dinosaurs
and if jurassic park taught us anything
it's that dinosaurs were actually closer
to birds than reptiles
due to their vertebrate shape it's even
now thought that dinosaurs had feathers
so it's a nice little nod to that theory
they unleashed the original founders
that wiped out the turkeys
and though they were once at war these
pilgrim and native themed creatures
team up to take them down this gives the
trio time to get to the monument
but the turkey president arrives and
says that turkeys are used to avoiding
predators
which is why they sleep in trees in the
wild this is actually true
and yes morty it turns out that turkeys
do genuinely sleep in trees
which yeah every day is a school day now
the turkey president says that they have
to either fight him or stop the rocket
but there's enough to go around the
president fights in the reflecting pool
which is next to the monument
and in space morty continues to use the
gun from the beginning to destroy more
landmarks
this includes the american flag which
was placed on the moon
and the monument as well rick manages to
behead one of the turkeys by pushing it
into the path of a passing satellite
i think this might be a reference to
speed in which keanu's character
managed to defeat dennis hoppers in the
same way which
yet spoiler alert also yeah shut the
hell up because
sometimes when i spoil movies that are
nearly 30 years old
right i'll get someone saying whoa
spoilers mate
but i'll tell you what yeah shut up
you've had 28 years to watch that movie
don't act like you were racing to see it
and i stopped you
you've had your time just shut the hell
up anyway thanks thanks for
sticking with me through this video i'm
back on earth the president manages to
stab the turkey version
and he pulls out a wishbone he wishes to
explode
and here we get several nodes to
predator and predator 2.
the predator of course self-destructed
at the end of the movie
and predator 2 culminated with the
aliens handing over a pistol from 1715
as a reward here the aliens give them a
musket
which they got from the predator and the
two races bury the hatchet
much like how rick and the president do
morty is told
that america has a dark history but the
president says to just feel thankful
and stop thinking about it the creative
team said that thanksgiving was
basically about sitting down and
shutting up for one meal
i think that's very much the message we
get here too the post-credits scene goes
to a supermarket
which is where we see a similar scene to
the ending of the hurt locker
in which coop still thinks he's a turkey
the pair now have their baby but are
still poor
even after all they gave up because
soldiers are often overlooked
it's a tragic ending which leaves him
eating berries off the floor
and his wife knowing that she'll
probably never get her husband back
because of all that he sacrificed this
might be a nod to western culture in
general
things like ptsd and the mental
illnesses that develop from war
and yes it's very very depressing
now as for the episode itself i felt it
was another pretty solid one that i
don't think
ranks amongst the best but it was still
very fun
so far the series has had a couple of
duds here and there
but overall i have quite enjoyed it and
i love how we watched morty go from
someone who's always sweating breaking
stuff and apologizing
to someone who doesn't care this had
some really fun landmarks and locations
in it
and though i probably didn't enjoy it as
much as my american cousins will have
due to not getting all of the references
i still had some fun with it
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the episode and obviously
i will have missed some things so the
comment section is yours to do as you
please
as a thank you for leaving something
you'll be entered into a competition on
the 30th of july
in which we're giving away three mcu box
sets all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the winners are picked out random at the
end of the month and the ones from last
month are on screen right now
so if that's you then message me on
twitter heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our brighton of
rick and morty last week which will be
linked on screen right now
a lot of work went into it posted it
four times it was that good and i'd
massively appreciate if you went over
there
as yeah it's it's a fun video now with
that all the way thank you for sitting
through this one
i mean paul i'll see you next time take
care peace